[Captions by Y Translator]
We've got a really cool project
coming up for you today.
Today's video is
sponsored by Casper.
They make fantastic mattresses,
and I thought if we're going
to have a great mattress,
we should have something
great to put it on.
So today we are building
the world's coolest bed frame.
This is not your
ordinary bed frame.
Trust me.
It's going to be amazing.
[Music]
We've got all our supplies.
You've got a bunch of tools.
So it's time to get started,
and the first thing I
actually did was to draw
the whole frame on SketchUp.
This is something I'm going
to use as a reference
to make sure I'm getting all
the right number of pieces,
and the right sizes,
and the right shapes,
and all of that good stuff.
But for now,
I think what we need to do is
take some of these 4x4,
and cut them down to size.
[Music]
At Home Depot,
I requested that they cut
these boards to 23 inches,
and they were pretty close.
I got 1/8 of an inch
under 23 inches.
That's why I measure to make sure
so I don't end up
with these posts being too long.
So now, we're going to measure
just under 23 inch segments,
and cut those off
of our 4x4 beams.
[Music]
Beautiful.
Perfect fit.
[Music]
Now, you can see the very
beginning of what we're going for.
The box is definitely
not finished.
But this will be one
of the front pieces,
that will be near the back.
There's actually going to be
an extension beyond this.
But this is the size
of the storage
that we're going to have inside.
Next, I'm also going to cut
a piece that goes right along
in between these two 4x4 posts,
that will divide it
right in the middle,
and offer support
down the middle of the bed.
You've seen that I used a lot
of screws to attach the 4x4
to these boards here
these ones do not have that,
and although there
will be a 4x4 beam
about in the middle on this,
what I'm going to do
to attach it to these is
drill holes all the way through,
and use some carriage bolts,
and that will give a really
strong connection to the post,
which will make it
so there's no play,
there's no wobble,
but it also makes it
so I can easily take it apart
when I need to move this.
This piece here can fit through
pretty much any door frame,
and through any hallway
that I need.
The whole bed
in its entirety can't,
but it should easily
dismantled down into pieces,
that I can carry or move.
After discussing it
with a friend of mine
who's an electrician,
I started working on the
electrical portions of the bed.
This thing is going
to have lights,
electricity, speakers,
the whole works.
[Music]
Two hours later.
The main frame of the bed
is now assembled.
We've got all of the stuff
to install into the headboard,
but I think at this point,
I'm going to throw
the mattress on,
but it's time for the unveil.
I have been using it Casper
mattress for several months now,
and I love it.
It's got like layers,
of different densities
of foam to give,
like just the right balance
between bouncy and soft.
So there's like
no pressure points and stuff.
It is a super great mattress.
I definitely love it.
Guys, if you're doing
what you're supposed to,
you should be spending 1/3
of your life asleep in bed,
getting 8 hours of sleep.
So you want to make sure
that you spend that time well
and be comfortable.
I also really appreciate
how convenient they
make it to order.
It comes delivered straight
to your door in a box
that's surprisingly small.
You're not really sure
how they squished it
mattress down like that,
and you get a 100 night
sleep on it trial.
So you actually get
to you it for like 3 months.
If after your 100-day trial
you decide it's not for you,
they have hassle-free returns,
shipping to you
and returning it is free,
if you're in the US and Canada.
If you want to get your own very
cool, super comfortable mattress,
head over to
Casper.com/TheKingofRandom,
and use promo code,
thekingofrandom to get 50 bucks,
off of selected mattresses.
Guys, the bed is done.
This has been a crazy big,
very fancy,
very complicated build.
But I am very excited
to have it all finished,
and to show you what it can do.
First off,
its a king-size mattress,
and you can see
that there's space on it.
In fact, if you look
underneath the bed cover,
there's actually just
a little bit of extra space
going all the way around,
and that was intentional.
I am quite tall.
I can quite easily
get into this bed
without any effort,
but a shorter person may want
something to put a knee on
as they climb up into the bed
or something like that.
So there is just a little bit
of a border going all the way,
around on the end here
that also works to help
lift up and down.
Now, the whole point
of this box shape,
and everything, was
that there's storage
underneath it.
And we have a 6 foot wide,
6 foot long,
2 foot tall storage room
underneath this bed.
Because it does have
the two gas struts installed,
it lifts up pretty easily even
with the mattress on top of it.
You can see I've got a lot
of space down there.
You can throw whatever you want.
It's going to be well
protected, well secured,
and you're not going to have
to worry about whether
this platform is going
to collapse onto it or anything,
because it is super sturdy.
Overall, this thing is strong,
and has just a lot
of space underneath it.
I've got some lights,
just in case you need
more visibility down in there.
There's actually not a lot
of need for it.
You can see on this side.
You can look all the way
into the back of it,
and you have pretty
good lighting but just in case.
You can see I've got
LED strip lighting going
all the way around.
Let's take a closer look at
how that's being installed.
Plugged into a power strip
that I will show
you in a minute.
It's just an LED control box,
that's got some wires
that come over to here.
This right here is the IR
receiver for the remote control.
This was just a role
of strip lighting
that I bought online.
It didn't come
in these plastic sheets.
So I actually bought
the track as well.
So I installed the track,
and then I installed
the lighting inside that.
I had to solder in a little bit
of wire as a joint,
so it would be able
to go around the hinge
when I open the bed,
and then of course,
goes back into
more track lighting.
So this goes all the way
around to the other side.
Let's take a look at it
with the lights off,
because it looks pretty cool.
Beautiful under lighting.
It's very fun.
All sorts of colors.
It comes pre-programmed
in the remote with a whole bunch
of different colors.
I actually often like to use red
before I'm going to sleep.
It makes it easier
for you to fall asleep,
blue lighting is going to keep
you awake a little bit more.
But if you're not trying
to go to sleep,
then it has just so many colors.
Party room!
What!
While I've got the lights off,
I can show you
another handy little thing.
It's got these two gooseneck
lamps that I can turn on.
These are just nice
little reading lights.
You can control it
from one side.
If you find
that it's too bright,
they're actually
dimmable as well.
So if I just hold
my finger on it,
it can get brighter.
Tap it again and hold,
and it gets dimmer.
Both sides of the bed have
an outlet with two plugs
and 2 USB ports.
It's very convenient for
anything you may want to charge
or leave plugged in on your bed.
We've also gone ahead,
and included some cup
holders on each side.
Sometimes, you just get thirsty.
It holds it really nicely,
and the cup holders
are collapsible.
So if you've got nothing
in there, you don't have
to worry about accidentally
bumping into it as you get
in and out of the bed.
I also have a couple
of speakers built
into both sides of the bed,
and the controls are built
into the center
of the headboard here.
[Music]
The speakers are set up so you
can either use an aux cord,
or you can just run it
all through Bluetooth.
[Music]
Casper foam mattresses.
They sleep pretty cool.
You don't tend
to over heat in them,
like you doing some kinds.
I however actually tend
to run fairly cool anyway,
which means that I like
a little bit more heat.
So what I've done is I just have
a heated blanket all over my bed
underneath the cover,
and the control for that just
sits right here next to my head.
The cord is running
under the mattress to here,
and then the power
cord comes down.
I have two power
outlets on the top.
But I've also added power outlets
on the inside of the legs here.
This is partly
because I've covered
up the outlet in the middle
of the wall behind the bed,
and I didn't want to make it
so you can't use it anymore.
So I've wired both of these,
there's one on each side,
into that center outlet,
and so we still have power.
You know, if you're vacuuming
the room or something like that,
you need to be able
to plug stuff in.
Or if you have a heated
blanket on your bed,
you need to be able
to plug it in somewhere.
That's why I've also added
some outlets here,
and I did put them on the inside
so that they
aren't really obtrusive.
They don't get in the way.
You don't see them too much,
but they are there
when you need them.
I've added 4 workbench casters
on to the bed.
2 here in the back,
and 2 on the inside
of the storage box.
Workbench casters are the type
where the wheel is actually
not in contact with the ground.
It looks like it is because of
this carpet is pretty thick,
but the wheel is not in
contact with the ground
until we engage it.
When we do that,
the wheel engages,
and it actually lifts up
the frame that it's on.
With all 4 casters engaged,
tt's possible to actually just
roll the bed a little bit.
It's not a great system
because it is on carpet,
and it's still
really big and heavy,
but it's a lot easier
than if you didn't have
those on there.
With that pulled out,
we can also take a look
behind the bed and see
what's going on.
Here are the plugs,
and you can see
that this outlet would really be
pretty inaccessible
for behind this bed.
So what I've done is I've set
up everything to be wired
into the bed itself.
One plug is coming
into this big old power strip
that I have attached with
these two makeshift brackets,
and most everything
plugs into that.
We've got our to bed
lights plug into that.
We've got our speaker system
plugged into that,
and we have the under
lighting all plugged
into this power strip.
The other plug is
what's powering the 4
outlets going around.
The outlets aren't on the same
circuit as the speakers,
the lights, and under lighting.
They have their own circuit,
and it just goes
all the way around.
So the 4 are on one circuit.
Obviously,
I can't run too much power
out of all of them at once,
but they're mostly for things
like the electric blanket,
or charging my laptop overnight.
You can also see
I've got a little piece
of foam right here.
This is a furniture slider,
and it's just to make sure
that if the bed does touch
the wall itself,
it's not going to I
should have too much.
Quick note about the bed frame,
first off, thanks to my friend Travis for
helping me come up with a design.
Second, if you are interested
in building one of these for yourself,
I have posted
the SketchUp file design
of this bed in description
for the video.
It doesn't have instructions
on how to build it.
It just shows you
all the pieces,
and where they go.
You will have to do a little bit
of figuring out of how to
attach everything yourself.
Thanks again to Casper,
for sponsoring this video.
Guys, if you want to get
your own very cool,
super comfortable mattress,
head over to
Casper.com/TheKingofRandom,
and use promo code
thekingofrandom to get 50 bucks
off of select mattresses.
Remember, shipping is free
in the US and Canada,
and you get to try
your mattress out worry free
for a hundred days.
Guys, that's all for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to her last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and if you hit this bomb in the center,
you'll be subscribe to our channel,
and that way you will
never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.